Speaker 1: Let's go next to
Alex from Baltimore. Alex, go.
Speaker 3: Hey, can you hear me?
Speaker 1: I can. Although it's.
Something's up with the connection, but let's see
if we can struggle through it.
Speaker 3: Oh, really? If.
Okay. How about now? Is that.
Speaker 1: Better? That's dramatically better.
Speaker 3: Okay. I just turned to. Okay.
And I also want to mention that I am in
a quiet room inside, so we shouldn't
have any loud annoyances outside.
Speaker 1: Have you treated
the walls with acoustic foam?
Speaker 3: I don't know if they did or
not. Okay. Anywhere. Okay. So I want to
ask you to analyze my take on Medicare for All
on a state level with the stories coming out of
California, I guess. Also, I live in Maryland.
The last governor's race, the Democrat was very
progressive, ran on Medicare for all, single
payer in the state of Maryland. Okay. And I was
a little hesitant on it because on a state level,
the funding mechanism is a better question to ask
because, you know, they can't just print money.
And balanced budgets actually matter. Yep. And
Maryland is such a small geographical state,
like I think you can be outside the state within
30 miles no matter where you live. And I think
it's more of a reasonable argument to say all the
all the people with means that you're going to try
to get funding for can just move to Pennsylvania,
Virginia, Delaware. So I was a little hesitant to
go with it on the state level. Is that a decent
take, do you think, or am I missing something?
Speaker 1: I'm not sure I understand what you're
saying. You're saying is it a problem for
state level Medicare for all that people
can move into the state from elsewhere keep.
Speaker 3: No, that because you have to raise
funds for a state. Yes. For Medicare for All.
And a lot of people are a lot of people aren't
going to be happy with having higher taxes, even
if it's cheaper in the long run. Okay. And and
in Maryland, you could move across the border to
Pennsylvania and not have to pay those taxes. So
you would lose a funding mechanism. Well, but.
Speaker 1: If you require people to be
residents to have the to participate in the
program, then don't you solve that issue?
Speaker 3: I suppose. But my I guess
my thought was if you have less,
if you have an influx of people moving out to
avoid it, then it's harder to raise funds for it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, but I think that that problem
that I don't think that's really a big thing
because if a state sets up state Medicare for
all, they say, okay, here's the way it works.
In order to be to have this single payer system
cover you, you've got to be a resident. That's
it. You've got to be a resident. So if people
from another state that doesn't have the system
come in, they can still be seen at hospitals.
But they have to bring insurance that they have.
Just like they do now. Do you see what I'm saying?
Speaker 3: Yeah, I guess I see what you're saying.
Speaker 1: So you can solve
that. That's a solvable problem.
Speaker 3: All right. Fair enough. And I'm.
No, you're at the end. Ooh. Quick question.
What is your favorite adult beverage?
Speaker 1: My favorite adult beverage?
I don't know. I'm partial to sort
of like wheat and white beers.
Speaker 3: Craft beer guy. Yeah.
Yeah, well, you should definitely
if you're ever in Baltimore, we have lots of
good craft beers. You can you can check out.
Speaker 1: Not IPAs, I hope. Right.
Speaker 3: They run the gamut of IPAs,
but there's lots of other stuff too.
Speaker 1: I don't want any IPAs
anywhere near me. That's my only thing.
Speaker 3: I actually agree with you.
There are some that I think are okay, but
no, I'm more of all lager. I actually like
dark beers now more than I used to. But anyways.
All right, thanks for taking my call. All right.
Speaker 1: Thank you for the call. And
what a beautiful note on which we can
end today. I'm always devastated that I can't
get to everyone who calls in, but we will take
calls again. And I hope to hear from you next
time. We'll take a quick break and be right bac